protesters and the police face off in
bogota
as demonstrations against government
proposed tax reforms turned violent
rocks were hurled at the police who
responded with flashbacks and tear gas
the protests here and in a dozen other
cities drew
some of the biggest crowds since the
start of the pandemic
that's despite attempts by the
government to dissuade the protesters
in a court order to postpone the
demonstrations due to a rise in covet-19
infections
i think the tribunal's decision further
angered people to come out
we're dealing with the worst government
proposals in decades
people are hungry and desperate for help
not more taxes
the reform proposed by president ivan
duques government
would raise taxes paid by people and
businesses
including the tax on basic food items
that were so far exempt
it would tax middle class pensions
utility bills
and even funerary services
the government is hoping to raise the
country's gross domestic
product by 2 percent it says it would
otherwise have to cut
public spending and could lose its
international debt
rating but the proposal has triggered an
angry response with people already
facing economic hardships due to the
pandemic
we're in the middle of a pandemic with
the majority of colombians unable to
stay home because they live
hand-to-mouth they eat eggs with rice
and now they want to tax the eggs
this tax reform is miserable
anger at the social and economic
policies of president ivan duque has
been simmering throughout the pandemic
there were major protests in 2019
against the increasing killings of
community leaders and the delay in the
implementation of the 2016
peace deal with farc rebels on wednesday
things also turned violent in colombia's
third serie kali
where some protesters burned buses and
looted stores
members of an indigenous tribe tore down
the statue of a spanish colonial
conquistador
the clashes show just how exasperated
people
are after more than a year into a
pandemic that have deeply affected the
economy here
the turnout was way higher than any of
the organizers had expected
and many people are now wondering if
this will be the beginning
of a new season of social upheaval in
the country
alessandra al jazeera bogota